欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课，:
同学们 这节课我们来讲一下关于店铺的SEO巧妙布局 让流量更加的精准
什么是SEO呢?就是搜索引擎优化 就是利用搜索引擎规则提升我们网站的自然排名
为什么要提升自然排名呢?因为只有提升自然排名你的产品
才能够有更多的机会展示出来 才能够吸引更多的买家进店
才能够促成更多的询盘和订单 是这样的
那么我们来看一下具体是怎么样去布局的
首先第一个我们要在产品跟店铺的界面都要做好详细的内容布局这样的话
要告诉系统告诉搜索引擎我们店铺是做什么的
我们店铺的偏好是什么样的全部把你所想要的信息告诉他那么整个平台就会给你的店铺
进行一个检索跟保存一下这些内容到时候
在买家搜索的时候就会根据这些内容
进行一个精准的匹配
这样才能够匹配到更加精准的买家
你的寻盘的质量才会更好
第一个比如说我们在写产品标题的时候一定要明确他的一个核心产品词是什么
他的产品主要是描述哪一类产品以及产品的属性详情页信息
都要非常精准的描述同一款产品
不要在同一个详情页中A信息描述C产品
B产品同时在一个详情页这是不合理的
必须是描述同一类产品比如说你A信息只能描述其中的一个产品就可以了
第二个就是关键词设置的时候一定要有核心词
比如说你的产品是位1那么你的核心词必须包含位1个词
不然的话系统不知道你在卖什么
第二个就是常委词一定要有因为这些词它的竞争度小那么更容易获得流量
这样就能够带动你整个链接有流量
第三个就是关键词设置和高铁要有一定的关系
比如说你刚才写的A这款产品那么你的标题里面这样描述
那么你的关键词K1 K2 K3就要跟这款产品有相关性同时是在描述同一款产品
这样的话那么你的这个相关性才大系统才知道你到底在卖什么
第三个就是店铺层级结构分析
一般来说就是我们店铺首页是不是会有产品分组这些一定要层次结构要清晰
第四个就是页面布局的话这个跟这个其实有点相似
这里的页面就是我们店铺里面所有产品的页面的集合就构建成了我们的一个店铺的网站
也就是我们店铺里面会有可能是500或者是1到2000个产品
这些产品是不是每个产品都有链接
这些链接是不是就构成了我们整个店铺的总链接
所以说这些相当于每一个产品链接每一个页面
这些一定要每一个都弄清楚或者是说
你每一个都要
写详细一点
店铺更新也就是我们说为什么要经常去更新一些新的产品
或者是发布一些
新的产品
这就是为了让搜索已经知道我们店铺经常在更新
让它收入你的内容
这样的话那么你的
总的流量就会更大一点点
如果是你这个店铺经常都不改动
没有人打理
那么是不是系统就认为你这个店铺不活跃
可能就是流量的分配啊或者排名都会下降
排名下降是不是就没有流量了
那么我们具体要怎么样去设置呢我们来看一下
店铺的后台
要怎么样去设置
一个就是
店铺的各项信息一定要完善而设置
第二个就是你看公司管理信息
精品中心产品管理这些标签
上级沟通这些都要
设置的完完整整的
这样一个是让
系统知道你在卖什么
第二个就是
让系统知道你这个
店铺更加偏好哪些品类
哪些人群
有哪些需求
更有利于系统精准的匹配流量
更容易来一些比较精准的水盘
所以这些都是
非常非常基础
但是很重要的信息设置
一定要做到位
一个店铺的基础现实
构建好
这样对于我们后期去做店铺运营是非常有促进的作用的
那么我们来看一下
后台
它到底是哪些板块需要设置
比如说
店铺管理这里面有一个管理公司信息
这里这些板块一定要设置好
你看这些板块都要设置好
让系统知道你在卖什么
还有这些核心信息展示这些都要设置好
接下来的话就是这些认证中心的这些
内容要用好
比如说你有哪些证书一定要全部上传
实力标签这些一定要设置好
你看这些都是会在
你万户的首页去展示的
你把这些实力的卡片全部选好
你看这些
你一定要选他都会在这些位置展示的都会在
详言页
展示的所以说你一定要选择
你最有优势的来进行一个展示就可以了
这些什么行业竞争力全部要用好
这些是非常重要的
一定要重视这个板块
那么这个就是我们所讲的一个基础的一个SEO布局
一定要重视这些最简单
而且最容易被别人忽略的一些店铺内部设置
把这些设置好了你再去进行各项内容的推荐
就可以了
这节课我们就讲到这里
下节课我们再见